[Music]
right it's six o'clock so we will get
started
welcome everybody thank you i have an
apology from councillor stuart
and
andrew is going to have to leave at 7.
seven
so can i have somebody
move those apologies thanks be accepted
thank you do i have a signer
thanks mark all those in favor say aye
those against that's carry
any conflicts of interest from anybody
that application has actually been
withdrawn
because the art show is not going ahead
so any other conflicts of interest
right the minutes of the last meeting
which seems so long ago
can i have somebody
move those
thanks mark a seconder
thanks andrea any discussion around
those any
issues i'll put that to the vote those
in favor say aye
goes against that's carried
any matters arising
nope we do not have any deputations or
presentations from the community don't
have any adjoined business
the one application to the grant phone
fund okay
good evening everyone
as shona has indicated the
pegasus bay school
sent me an email this morning
withdrawing their application
the life education trust canterbury
interesting application
but i think well worthwhile
obviously up to the board to decide
whether or not it falls within their
delegated
powers of
criteria and such like
but yeah happy to answer any questions
if i can
andrea
um madam chair back to the the pegasus
bay school pta just trying to be
proactive for them
i was actually going to
put forward that we decline it only
because of what they were requesting
being the advertising for
essence
i looked at the other costs that were
involved
and picked out there was one for
children's entertainment of 350.
the reason behind it
is i feel it's quite an indulgent method
of advertising for a school
and i question
what who their audience would be through
that magazine
but if it had been for the children's
entertainment then i would be supportive
of it
i don't know if it needs to be put in
the minutes men and she would just go if
they come back again and ask i don't
know
so i think each application is
measured
at the time yeah um
yeah
thank you
any questions about the life education
trust any
thoughts
anybody want to move something
phillip
uh just speaking to the motion briefly i
have actually met harold
um two two weeks ago my
uh grandsons
attended the um
trailer unit and had some lessons
and i've also been showing how the
program works and um it's quite an
amazing program
and
it is
to be used in north canterbury it's not
going into the general coffers as i
understand it
so it is quite an expensive program to
roll out they have qualified staff
purpose-made classroom
so some of your own children may have
benefited from it
my grandson who is nine came home
and said it was disgusting
guess what they talked about
things that he hadn't talked about with
his mother but um i i think it is very
beneficial and i'm certainly supportive
of helping them
[Music]
um
yes we've
as the board knows themselves there's
always been a bit of
uncertainty in regards to
do we
fund
schools or don't we this board is always
being quite
pragmatic in
looking at
the actual program
and deciding whether or not they are
happy to fund
um
this as i'm sure you've probably aware
is a move by rangiora um
ashley community board to try and
clarify
to make
deciding whether or not to
fund schools easier and and give the
schools more
direction on whether or not
they should be funded
it's entirely up to the board
whether or not they
prefer to have
more of a
ability to use discretion
rather than being tied down to
thou shalt
or shalt not it's entirely up to you
i will say that oxford oh
decided not
to amend their criteria
but it's up to the board
questions anyone
into a question
madam chair are you aware that creative
communities have a criteria for funding
uh
for art and related activities
oh i could answer that question madam
chair
they have an exclusion that creative
communities don't fund
things which the ministry of education
would fund
if it's part of the normal school
curriculum
and to get over that line a school
principal will have to provide a letter
saying that the art type activity is not
funded by their bulk grant and is
outside their normal curriculum
so whether we need to put this in we'll
talk about that but
um other
organizations do consider that point
courtney you were there
pretty much it was just up to the
discretion
so that they
with it all without it they can still
accept a application from a school so if
you put that new course in
and the school doesn't play you still
have the discretion
i think the idea was that by saying
if a school is requiring
funding
the pta would fill in the application
and if it comes from the pta
it would be taken that it isn't
something that the minister of education
would fund i think that's what the idea
is behind
specifically stating ptos
do we have many applications from actual
boards of trustees or
uh actually would
ring or actually have had a few so
that's what's caused them
we've had a school which has
had an application from the school from
the bot and from the
pta for different projects and i think
that's just trying to close the loop
going to cause a problem yes i think
they are still leaning towards
consistency
so it will look at how many boards want
and how many don't and just hopefully we
don't have two
i really don't see what the difference
is between either one there's not one
strong
way or another they both any application
can be
considered anyway by the board
am i right in thinking that
it doesn't really matter if it's either
or
at the moment
well
the b amendment still says we can
consider
and status quo this is what we're doing
currently at the moment
will be considered
if we're going to say direct from
i i do agree that a board of trustees
should not be applying
i just don't think that when they're
running from a completely different
budget than a pta is
when i've been on the years and years of
pta it's always been about the fluffy
things
whereas a board is there for the um
operational and things like that there
so
yes we have not had an issue yet but
maybe we'll in the future i'm not sure
um but we'll consider staff's
recommendation of how to proceed
i was just going to test meeting madam
chair and move a and c
there's a seconder
just briefly i think we've had no
difficulties with the status quo
we have the discretion to decline any
application as we see fit
so it leaves it more open for us
personally i would be opposed to funding
anything that the ministry should be
paying for but that's something that can
come up at a meeting
no phillips done very well
sorry any questions from anyone
right i'll move that my report be
accepted do i have a secondar
thanks andrew
all those in favor say aye
goes against it's carried
[Applause]
matters for information
anybody got any questions around any of
those
do i have someone to move that those be
received the information be received
thank you mark a seconder
any comments
right all those in favor of that
say aye
those against
that's carried
members information exchange um
councillor stewart did put in a brief
written
thing around water today so um we'll
email that around so you have a chance
to read that to everybody
andrew you've got
anything for the
information exchanges
and proposals at waikoku beach and
we're asking council staff to
to come up with a sort of a concept plan
as to how they might
um
all co-exist
at the beach in areas that are seen to
be um
acceptable for each of them and together
so
we had a good meeting there and sometime
in november i think it is council staff
will come back to
to come back with a proposal that it
will be discussed with the community
down at the beach
it was a good meeting yeah yeah a good
way and a good way of tackling it i
think given that sort of
lay out a sort of a plan that um some of
these ideas be there the volleyball
courts or this pump track or the board
riders can then um so here's the
opportunity for you
uh and then um go ahead and they can
whereas at the moment there's some um
it's a bit tricky some things i think
we're slowing things down for one or two
of those entities because there's not a
clear framework for them there's not a
place for them to go
yeah
it's all around that
is trying to get everything in the in
the right place
that suits the community
you know at this time
um because once land's being used for
something it can't really be used for
anything else so we've got to make sure
that whatever goes in is actually in the
right place
so
grant stevens is
involved with us as well thank you grant
philip an update from you
thank you madam chair i'll be brief i
didn't get to put anything in writing i
can blame covert for that
at the council we've been pretty busy on
the three waters mata we've had a number
of briefings
and we had an extraordinary meeting on
the 28th of september
and unanimously passed a series of
resolutions which basically say we don't
support the current model
we also expressed concern with the role
of lgnz than promoting the reform
and the mayor has written to them
requesting that they consider feedback
from their sector
and possibly have a meeting
to reassess their position
the district plan review has been
advertised and the council has appointed
neville atkinson and nikki mailings
as the two council appointees
there are some external commissioners
and an eway
commissioner to be appointed and i'm
still waiting to hear who those people
are
there have been a number of drop-in
sessions um including one at pegasus
last week
that i attended um it wasn't very well
attended
they weren't actually drop-in sessions
they were public
awareness sessions i'm calling it a
drop-in session but it was an awareness
session you're correct
um people weren't very aware because i
don't think anyone came uh they weren't
advertised
and that was the way they wanted it they
just wanted to get people as they passed
by and i did suggest that nobody
actually really passed by there and that
was
rather a waste of time and there was one
at the wooden community centre last
friday
um which i don't know how many i would
have no idea of anybody i didn't get to
the woody one but the pegasus one you're
right there was no foot traffic passing
by we did however adjourn to the flat
white cafe and um harassed a book club
and told them about what was going on so
that was quite successful
you may have also read the council
approved the restoration of the po
if i've pronounced that correctly uh the
budget for that is somewhere around
twenty thousand but could go up to 30
000 depending how you read the
recommendation
but um it is a very special piece of art
should we say
so um
hopefully that will get underway shortly
creative new zealand we had a number of
applications
which
we approved
the creative community to waimakariri
committee assessment committee
and we approved those on the 15th of
september there will be another round
early next year and we would encourage
artists or people with an art type
activity and it is art in the broader
sense of the word
keep an eye out because we do have money
to allocate to qualifying
things
i thought you might also
be aware
i attended the pegasus medical center
for my vaccination
so i'm keeping it local
and i'm going back next week for number
two
so um as i have seen uh someone
madam chair promoting on social media
there are vacancies in north canterbury
if you go looking for them
and in actual fact um pegasus was very
good and i was very pleased with the
service
i'm pleased to say so far no side
effects
i also attended the woody flower show
which was here last
saturday or sunday saturday was it
[Music]
and that was very well attended that
might have been
saturday a week ago it's on the 2nd of
october
a local resident
also wrote to nzta and i forwarded his
letter to you i don't know whether
you've seen that man
thanks he was talking about
safety improvements through what end
and
it does look like good news
it says how focus is currently on
improving safety along the road through
wood end
funding for the design stage of safety
improvements and its approaches have
been approved under the national land
transport port program as part of the
road to zero strategy
so really they say they've started work
but
really i thought i heard something like
this about a year ago so it hasn't
really moved on very far but it is still
on the table
and the final thing i was just going to
say the enterprise north canterbury
awards are now rescheduled for the 20th
of november for anyone going it's a
really good night if you haven't got
your ticket
it's a big venue it's at main power
stadium
so that's it from me thanks for andrea
did you have a question
ah that hasn't been decided a hundred
percent yet because there is a heritage
fund
that's been mooted
it it's also a creative it's an artistic
thing so
it's possible some may come from there
it may come from a you know a bucket of
sources
but the council have approved
in principle and approved the finance
but where it's actually coming from i
couldn't say there was also a suggestion
of
the sports
landscaping fund for entrances
could be a possibility but i would
assume if that's the case it would come
back to us
will knight be approached do you know
yes they have been approached they don't
have any funding available
thanks phillip um
where did the letter come from about the
roading
uh that guy
since we're in a public session i don't
know that i should mention the
resident's name but it's a local wooden
resident who will be well known to you
who wrote to the minister of transport
i think he was prompted after he saw a
press release the work was resuming
after the covert lockdown
and uh so he got on his bicycle and uh
started
talking to minister wood
yes yes which i asked him if i could
share and he said he was happy for me to
share the content
yeah yeah shona's got one or i could
email it
uh the minister probably referred it to
it's come from an andrew thak ray
national manager infrastructure delivery
so that's for the funding
for the planning but not the actual
implementation design so
yeah this is the design phase they're
working towards that
i would assume that
the funding is not likely to be an issue
although the mayor was going to clarify
what funding was granted in the last
round and i haven't heard the outcome of
that
there's no suggestion suggestion funding
is not available here because they're
proceeding
preparatory with their
uh design
i mean i think it's good that it's still
on the table and they're working towards
it they're not saying it's been shelved
or it's not happening
they're saying they are
our focus is currently on improving
safety along the road through wood end
funding
has been approved sorry
for the safety improvements so they're
at the design phase and then it will
happen
would be prudent since they were
so savvy and sending a letter back to a
resident that they should come here and
give us an update
about where they're at the
moment it is actually something i've
been thinking about around inviting nzta
um
but it was sort of put on hold because
the mayor had organized was trying to
organize a meeting with the chief
executive of nzta and other ncta
officials that was due to be
october
i was invited to attend that meeting
that has now been deferred until
possibly 10th of november
from nzta
so
yeah
adam chair there is a new um regional
manager uh guy called james cagle
and i think you should test an
invitation to james to come along
it has been a year
since nzta came along to a meeting when
they basically said that yes we're in
the design phase
and
nothing
really so um
i think with nzta deferring the meeting
with the mayor and there is no guarantee
that that will go ahead on the 10th of
november
i think it would be good to actually
issue an invitation to um
whatever their title is now whether it's
the same as it used to be of the
regional manager of south island
relationships
john james cagle i'd be happy to second
that madam chair
so you're happy if we do that
sort of
i i mean i'd rather we write to them and
just get them get a written response
last time they came and spoke to us and
we spent
probably an hour a good hour on it at
the sefton hall and really we got
nowhere it was just a whole lot of talk
and i mean i think if you get something
this is this is probably the best i've
seen not that i've read it properly but
best i've seen a long time so why don't
we just write to them and say we want to
know you've got your money approved
what's your time frame what's your
when's it going to happen i mean talking
to them is not well that's what we've
done and we've got nowhere
that's what that's my thing but writing
to them in the past has got nowhere no
but so
coming along and just talking about
something wasting an hour is not really
i think i'd rather see the productivity
of a letter or in a response like this
with it with the time frame
how about both that we actually write to
them with all the details of what has
gone on before
and
where we are and then
invite them to attend a meeting as well
yep
and when they can explain uh
yep that's happy with it
is everybody okay with that approach yes
okay that's what we'll do
thank you john
thanks for that update phillip um the
other thing around the po is also the
garden
um underneath the pose getting quite
overgrown
which i have
suggested to grant mccloud that that
needs some maintenance done on it so
that the lights actually shine up
on the po
um
but again that is a that's a thing
that's a project that's been going for
some time now
um yeah
i just add that the po is not actually
on council land no it's not it's on the
golf course land so one of the things
the council has resolved to do is see if
they can enter into an agreement with
the golf course over the ongoing
maintenance and the ability for the po
to remain where it is
and maybe clarify its status
that's good
andrea um just a suggestion um and i
apologize i don't know the right formula
or as you we all know that there's a lot
of work that is done at um in pegasus by
um
the pd
team
could this may be an extension to their
work they do currently
to actually
the work they do within pegasus is
through the
trust
that's the only one that actually
uses the pd
system is around
around pegasus so
yeah i don't know i mean the maintenance
of the po themselves i mean the
suggestion that it you know could come
to our landscaping budget as well it you
know would take
two years of our landscaping budget to
pay for it with nothing else happening
so um
to to me it seems that the power is
actually
um
for the whole waimakariri district is
something that is
you know we don't have a lot on state
highway one that is really visible as is
you know being part of waimakariri it
was gifted
um
from the ewe at kaikoura and um
you know erected there so
you know there has to be a degree of
respect
and
and i do regard it as a treasure not
only now but in the future um and i
think it should be recognised
as such for the district
that's my opinion
mark have you got an update
we had the wedding community association
agm on a zoom
meeting which we had to so
wasn't that well attended but that i
didn't expect it to be
um we got a new lynn petrie's come on as
a representative from ravenswood which
was although she didn't attend the first
meeting but that was quite good and had
quite a conversation with her around i
think we disgusted it
maybe the last meeting we had around the
um
you know ravenswood would end
probably not so much pegasus link but
trying to get
um and i said to her you know i
think that having another
if ravenswood too would have formed
their own group it's just another group
if but where they were more than welcome
to join
because we see it as as one
um
and then we had our first meeting last
monday night
and we the safety uh upgrades were one
of the things which is this helps
clarify a little bit and i did speak to
dan about what else and i've spoken to
shown about what else we could do as an
association to try and i mean i think
the more ways you push the
safety concerns or the whole roading
issue it doesn't matter which way it
goes from it's just
everybody um
and we also talked about the welcome to
what ends signs which um i think we're
going to talk about hopefully a bit
later on
that just a lack of progress on it so
um
we've are planning the woody end
cultural and um school hungry day um
community and cultural day at the school
on the 19th of november so whether we
have it or not i'm not sure it'll just
depend
we'll make a decision probably next
monday when school returns to go because
there is quite a lot of planning in it
um
and
basically this community association can
get the funding and fund the whole thing
for the school and the community to
attend so if that does happen obviously
well this group would be and others
would be invited
um i went to the men's shed opening
which was a um
great acknowledgement to the green space
team and grant and grant we're you know
um acknowledged for the great work and
how quick i think dan sits the quickest
project accounts we've ever done
it was um it was amazing it was a good
turnout and it's look it's a great um
facility for all woody and pegasus and
ravenswood
i think they're like they'll only grow
now as membership grows and they've got
a home and they've got
so i also talked to them about the
possibility of having a
community garden there because we're
trying to um we're trying to work on
getting one on chinery's road around the
but the council said it wasn't an
appropriate space but there are a few
people interested in doing that um
and i went to the wedding flower show as
well which was
not something i'd normally go to but it
was
there was a lot of people from the
community were here it was good they
were absolutely wrapped with the turnout
so
that's it
um they're also quite uh
quite a few people have expressed an
interest in pegasus about setting up a
community garden so
whether if one was set up around that
men's shed that it could actually be
perhaps better combined
yeah they said they wouldn't be
interested in doing themselves that's
not their game but what they would do is
make help make raised gardens or yeah
and i think there could be multiple
places i mean it's sort of next to the
school
there's a swimming pool area the kids
have um and it's only not utilized at
all but it's
i think it's having people that want to
you know actually want to
like i said i'd be happy to help with it
but i couldn't do it on an ongoing i
can't keep up with my own garden so but
you know a thing for retired people or
people who've got a bit of time and i
think also
could feed the pantry which is right
next door so
but yeah i think there could be multiple
in time so
thank you
there's just
just a point uh look there'll be i'm
sure people associated with the food
forest in kaiapoi and community gardens
and kaiapoi who'd be only too pleased to
come and provide a bit of advice as to
how to progress things
might even get them to do some work
[Music]
as planting down the um
cam river
um
what turned out to be a really bitter
day but
and the planting wasn't easy as i
expected
i thought i was just going to have to
dig my spade in like that and it was
breaking through from pretty great big
brutes and
anyway it was it was a
good day and a lot of people here it was
got a lot of plants and
um
so all the other things i've been
involved with just you know
really sustainability
the rural drainage committee
um
and of course i've been to the opening
of the
the new center
and um
it's probably i i can't remember
everything to tell you the truth i sent
it off to cavern
i couldn't find it in here
um john i did send it back to you
because you had put it through for
july and were actually ended august and
september
i'm sure you could have actually changed
that's coming
no you had it for july john the dates
were were for july
that summer
yeah you did july and august
and we were looking for august september
i sent you an email asking you to
update it i'm sorry
i'll take the blame for that
simon anything else
uh no man of cheer um just
thinking about sorry about how to
leverage you know
knowledge in one part of the district to
another and things like food forests and
community gardens there's
there's people who just love that stuff
and will be only too policed to help i'm
sure
about that at
all i also attended um
the agm of the audience communitization
by zoom
and
another meeting last week
yeah they were really
okay it was quite good
i
i think mark filled you know a lot of
the stuff so
yeah
so there was some other things i'd done
dan adria sorry
um back to acknowledging what simon said
in regards to the fantastic for example
is kai boy
with
the forest there and brent ken's is an
incredible ambassador for that and
they've just written their constitution
actually in a process around actually
repeating what they're doing so well
so
i know brent would be happy to replicate
and they already as probably people know
here that they give the excess from the
kaiapoi food to pegasus
currently which is just tremendous so
yeah so we definitely have a wonderful
connection there don't we sign
um on to me it's been pretty simple it's
been uh with north carolina neighborhood
support we're working on our submission
to council for the district plan
and
i have also been doing a lot with the
pixar's residence group through a couple
of things there um
that i won't talk to this in this forum
but um that has those two have kept me
very busy over these last few weeks so
thank you
thanks andrea well the district plan yes
district plans out for consultation at
the moment so that's the one big one so
you know please do what you can to to
make people aware of it um there are
drop-in sessions planned there's one
plan for wood end but i can't quite
remember when
um
we're
attempting to get one um at pegasus but
i'm not sure how that has actually gone
so far so i can't tell you about that
one
um and we've got our workshop coming up
in a fortnight yeah
so start thinking about
that for our submission
thanks kay
um if members could please send whatever
questions you have prior to the
submission workshop
i've got a spreadsheet running so that
we've get that information
and hopefully make your submission
workshop more useful
the other one is a speed limit review in
and around our towns that closes next
monday
there seems to be a bit of comment
around the sefton township around the
proposed speed limit through there which
is interesting
so i'm not sure what'll come out of that
seem to be a little bit divided so
that'll be quite interesting
um
board funding update these are balances
there
media items
i'll come up with something
i'm sure
no questions understanding orders no
urgent general business
so the next meeting is again at the
wooden community centre on monday the
8th of november
so i'll see you then
but i will officially close this meeting
and we will move to
workshop with grant on our landscaping
budget
yeah
thanks grant
what you've got for us
you